طائره سوفيتيه الصنع في طريقها الى ميدان
المعارك في اوكرانيا ستكون في يد القوات
الاوكرانيه للروسيه للمره الاولى تتسلم
طائرات النفاثه منذ بدايه الحرب تقدم
الجارتان سلوفاكا وبولندا حزمه اولى من
هذه المقاتلات التي تمتلكها قائد سلاح
الجو الاوكراني يرحب بالمج وعينه على الاف
سته عشر الامريكيه يقول المسؤول الاوكراني
ان ميغ تسعه وعشرين لن تحل المشكله لكنها
ستسهم في تعزيز القدرات الاوكرانيه تتمنع
واشنطن حتى الان عن تلبيه الرغبات
الاوكرانيه يقول المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي ان قرار بولندا لا يغير
الحسابات الامريكيه فيما يتعلق بطائرات اف
16 تقلل روسيا من اهميه هذا الدعم يقول
ناطق باسم ان الامر اشبه بمحاولات اتلاف
المعدات القديمه غير الضروريه في بولندا
ويجدد المسؤول الروسيه التهديد بان
المساعدات الغربيه لاوكرانيا ستتعرض
للتدمير تمت اسئله عن البنيه التحتيه
والتشغيل والتدريب لهذه الطائرات دمرت
القوات الروسيه منذ الاسابيع الاولى للحرب
90 في المئه من المطارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه هذا يعني ان حركه هذه الطائرات
ستكون صعبه الا اذا تمكن الاوكرانيون من
اعاده تاهيل هذه المطارات او حمايه ما
تبقى منها في مناطق لا تصل اليها الضربه
الروسيه هذا الامر لا يبدو سهلا القوه
الروسيه تسيطر بشكل كامل على الاجواء
الاوكرانيه من ناحيه ايجابيه بالنسبه
للاوكرانيين فان الطيارين ليسوا بحاجه
للتدريب على هذه الطائرات فاوكرانيا
الدوله السابقه في الاتحاد السوفيتي
خبرتها طويله في استخدام الاسلحه
السوفييتيه كانت تمتلك ميغ تسعه وعشرين
قبل ان تدمرها روسيا في الحرب هذا يسهل
على الجنود الاوكرانيين استخدام هذه
بفاعليه عاليه مقارنه بالحاجه للتدريب على
طائره اف 16 الامريكيه في الجغرافيا تجد
ميغ تسعه وعشرون مكانها في الخطوط
الاماميه للجبهه يتوقع خبراء ان تؤدي دورا
في سد فجوه في الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني
بالاضافه الى استهداف القوات الروسيه في
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها باقليم دونباس
والمناطق الجنوبيه الاهم هو ان هذه الميغ
في يد البولنديين تطورت ليضاف اليها
صواريخ هارم الامريكيه وهي صواريخ مضاده
للرادارات تعمل بكفاءه ضد المواقع الروسيه
على الارض الاوكرانيه هكذا تبدو امدادات
بولندا وسلوفاكيا اضافه نوعيه لصالح
اوكرانيا لكنها في الوقت نفسه تفتح الباب
امام الاسئله اللوجستيه وامد هذه الحرب في
عامها الثاني